Wounded in similar ways, wounded in similar ways. It sounds like something that a hippie would say, but the truth is we're wounded in similar ways. All right. Welcome to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, the only podcast about therapy on the internet that is cool and gets it. Alice Hawley, what do you do to stick it to the man? Well, primarily, um, I
以相似的方式受伤，以相似的方式受伤。这听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话，但事实是我们确实以相似的方式受伤。好了。欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客，这是互联网上唯一一个既酷又懂行的心理治疗播客。Alice Hawley，你平时做什么来反抗体制？嗯，主要是，嗯，我
do therapy for one thing. James Waits, do you see through the lies of society? Yes. We need like some gnarly like Gen X rap rock to to lead us in here. If you all have any suggestions, I'll throw that at the beginning. Like, yeah, yeah. So welcome to the Taffy Therapy Collective Podcast. We're gonna start doing some kind of roundtable discussions. And for the first one, we thought it would be fun to just kind of talk about topics that we may do during those we do Consultations as a practice and a lot of the conversations that come up in consultations were like hey, what's going on in society?
做心理治疗，这是一方面。James Waits，你能看穿社会的谎言吗？是的。我们需要一些像那种硬核的 X 世代说唱摇滚来作为开场。如果你们有什么建议，我会在开头放进去。对，对。所以欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。我们打算开始做一些圆桌讨论。对于第一次，我们觉得聊聊我们在咨询中可能会涉及的话题会很有趣。作为一家诊所，我们在咨询中经常会遇到这样的对话：“嘿，社会上发生了什么？”
What's going on in therapy? How are those things interacting? Are kind of interesting and would make really good podcasts, but you can't record the consultation for a couple reasons One of them is because like every other question is about how to use something in our EMR and that wouldn't make for great podcasting. But hopefully we can bring just kind of, cause you know, our audience is generally like trauma patients, trauma therapists, and kind of trauma nerds interested in the psychology of different things. And we hopefully can get into some interesting topics.
“心理治疗中发生了什么？”这些事情是如何相互作用的？这些话题很有趣，也很适合做成播客，但由于一些原因，你不能录制咨询过程。其中一个原因是，每隔一个问题都是关于如何在我们的电子病历（EMR）系统中操作，那可做不出好的播客。但希望我们能带来一些内容，因为你知道，我们的听众通常是创伤患者、创伤治疗师，以及对各种心理学感兴趣的“创伤极客”。希望我们能深入探讨一些有趣的话题。
So this one, if you hear something you like, leave a comment. And maybe that will be an episode soon. So we can go through different things that might make for a good roundtable discussion. I don't know. I was thinking about having like the y'all's perspective or therapists talking about like
所以这一期，如果你听到了喜欢的内容，请留下评论。也许那很快就会成为一集节目。我们可以讨论各种可能适合圆桌讨论的话题。我不知道。我一直在想，是不是可以从你们的角度，或者让治疗师们聊聊……
therapy and movies, therapy and TV. Because it does seem like that's changing a lot, like that old kind of paradigm where HBO would have a show like The Sopranos are in treatment, where somebody would just be in sort of like a relational, you know, more rogerian kind of like talk therapy with a little bit of psychoanalytic stuff and maybe some CVT suggestions forever. That just seems to be going away. Like there's a little bit more nuance in how screenwriters are talking about it, but there's still screenwriters. I was watching that show, The Pit on HBO. Have you all seen that? Oh, I've seen an episode. Yeah, I mean, it's, it's, it's okay. But it was like, just something that was like on in the background when I have to do
心理治疗与电影、心理治疗与电视。因为这看起来确实在发生很大变化，比如过去那种 HBO 会有的剧集，像《黑道家族》或《扪心问诊》，剧中某人会进行一种关系导向的、罗杰斯式的谈话治疗，带一点精神分析，可能还有一些认知行为疗法（CBT）的建议，一直持续下去。那种模式似乎正在消失。编剧们在谈论心理治疗时确实多了一些细微差别，但他们毕竟还是编剧。我当时在看 HBO 的那部剧《医院》（The Pit）。你们看过吗？哦，我看过一集。是的，我的意思是，它……它还可以。但它就像是我在做……
Excel sheets. And, but, and it's clear that they had like medical advisors that were like making sure they didn't put like the, you know, the IV bag upside down or something. But they couldn't really change the script. And there are some things about hospitals and cycles just like, okay, I see what you googled, and then didn't understand how that actually works. Like, I don't know, for example, there's a scene in the beginning where one of the people's like, or no, it's like,
Excel 表格时在后台播放的东西。很明显，他们有医学顾问，确保他们不会把静脉输液袋挂反之类的。但他们无法真正改变剧本。关于医院和循环，有些事情就是……好吧，我看得出你们查了谷歌，但没搞懂它实际上是怎么运作的。比如，我不知道，举个例子，开头有一个场景，其中一个人说……或者不，它是……
in the beginning of one of the episodes, but it's like further into the season, but this, they're, they're trying to talk on like, sort of like every liberal talking point, like they're talking about gun violence and hospitals being overwhelmed, and like the healthcare system failing and like all these things that like, I think are probably good to talk about. Um, but some of the, some of the stuff, especially around mental health is like, now you kind of got to understand how this works a little bit better.
在其中一集的开头，但那是季中比较靠后的部分，他们试图谈论每一个自由派的话题，比如枪支暴力、医院不堪重负、医疗体系崩溃等等，这些话题我认为讨论起来可能是有益的。嗯，但是其中一些内容，尤其是关于心理健康的，你现在得稍微了解一下它是怎么运作的才行。
Um, like there's a guy that comes in and they're like, why are you homeless or something? And he's like, oh, well I'm homeless because I can't afford my schizophrenia medication. And they're like, okay, well, it needs like, yeah, I went 40 years of marriage and hard work, but then I lost my job. So I smoked crystal meth and I got the schizophrenia from the crystal meth. And you're like, no, you can't get schizophrenia 40 from like, you could get an anxiety disorder, but schizophrenia like that isn't you don't catch it's not catching, you know, and then they and then the doctors are either like, like a social worker comes in and you can tell they've heard that assertive community
比如，有个家伙进来了，他们问：“你为什么无家可归？”之类的。他说：“哦，我无家可归是因为我买不起精神分裂症的药。”他们就说：“好吧，那需要……”就像，“是的，我经历了 40 年的婚姻和努力工作，但我失业了。所以我吸了冰毒，然后因为冰毒得了精神分裂症。”你会觉得：“不，你不能因为吸冰毒就得精神分裂症。”你可以得焦虑症，但精神分裂症不是那种……你不会传染上它，你知道的。然后医生们……或者一个社会工作者进来了，你可以看出他们听说过“断言社区治疗团队”（ACT）的存在，但他们并不完全知道那是什么。她说：“好吧，你只需要问急诊室，他们就会把思瑞康（Seroquel）送到你的无家可归者营地。”然后其中一个急诊医生说：“太棒了，为什么不呢？我想成为那个去做的人。我能在值班时离开急诊室，每周给这家伙送药吗？”他们就说：“太好了，问题解决了。”
treatment teams exist, but they don't quite know like what those are. And she's like, Well, all you have to do is ask the emergency room and they'll just bring you your Sarah quill into your homeless encampment. And like one of the ER doctors is like, Yeah, that's a great idea. Why don't you just I'd like to be the one who does it. Can I just leave the ER on shift and like, go bring this guy medication weekly? And they're like, yeah, problem solved.
就像是，不，这……这不应该那样运作，可能。但这……这根本不是那样运作的。所以，总之，我觉得那会是一个有趣的话题。你们在电视电影中还看到过其他关于心理治疗和心理健康护理的趋势吗？尤其是……你们看过 HBO 的《企鹅人》吗？是的，我看过。是的，是的。蝙蝠侠，《黑道家族》。它比我想象的要好。是的，你们看到那个 EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）……
It's like, no, like this isn't like yet. Should work that way, probably. But this is this is not this is not the way. So anyway, I think that would be an interesting one. Any any other like trends you'll see on on like TV movies with With the therapy and and mental health care, especially I don't have y'all seen the penguin like the show on HBO Yeah, yeah, I did. Yeah. Yeah Batman Sopranos. It was better than I thought it was gonna be Yeah, did you did you see the the EMDR?
疗程了吗？我想那是……哦，是的，没错。对，就像……我不了解漫画里的东西，所以那是谁？那个女士是谁？她是反派吗？她在漫画里吗？我知道她是一个小众反派，我想她是……我的意思是，她可能非常重要。我脱离 DC 漫画世界已经有一段时间了，但我喜欢他用的那个机器。我喜欢那个光，那个光照 EMDR 机器，他不需要用手。那是……那只是个灯光设备，对吧？
Sessions I think that oh, yeah, that's right. right yeah like I don't know the comic stuff so who is that like who is the lady like what is her villain is she in the comics or something I know she's a niche villain I think she's like I mean she might be very big I am I've been removed from the DC comic world a good bit but I just like that machine he had I like that light the light EMDR machine where you didn't have to use his hands. Is that- It's just the light device, isn't it?
就像那个来回移动的横条。是的。是的。所有这些，当我接受 EMDR 培训时……我大概有三年没做过 EMDR 了，因为脑点疗法（Brainspotting）对我来说几乎完全取代了它。但确实，大多数整天做 EMDR 的从业者……
Like it's the bar that goes back and forth. Yeah. Yeah. All that, when I trained at EMDR, like I haven't done EMDR for probably three years because brain spotting just kind of replaced that almost entirely for me. But yeah, most of the practitioners that did EMDR all day,
他们相当纯粹。EMDR 提供者有时往往有点像邪教。他们会每节课都专门做这个。这就是他们告诉我们的，而且这在当时感觉非常重要。我不知道，那个横条，可能有一些好莱坞的成分在里面，因为我不认为大多数治疗师……因为你只需要眼睛动就行了，它其实……离得越远，头动得越久，是的，是的。我不知道，Alice，你有没有注意到任何心理治疗……我的意思是，我的电视内容相当冷门。我主要看那种“最好的家伙”和真人秀，非常糟糕的真人秀。但它也会出现在那里。
they were pretty purist. EMDR providers tend to be kind of culty some of the time. And like they would just do it exclusively for every session. And that's what they told us is like, and good bit like this was huge it felt like I don't know though the bar it probably some Hollywood stuff there like I don't think most therapists because you just need the eyes to move it doesn't really the further it is away though the longer heads yeah yeah I don't know else what do you notice any any therapy and my I mean my TV content is pretty off, off the off the beaten path. I mostly watch like that's the best guy and reality, really bad reality to me. But it pops up in there, too.
是的。但我的意思是，关于……我不知道，真实犯罪类的内容总是吸引我，你知道，我工作中接触受害者，有点喜欢施虐者的心理，那是一个很好的观点。你能把麦克风稍微靠近一点吗？你的声音有点被挤压了，很难听清。我想降噪功能有点……我可以把那一行剪掉。是的，是的，那是个好观点。我不知道。是的，继续说。听起来很棒。
Yeah. But I mean, the stuff about, I don't know, the true crime stuff is always like appealing to my like, you know, the part of me that like works with victims and kind of loves the psychology of the abuser and That's a good point Could you put your mic a little bit closer? You're just a little a little pinched. It's kind of hard to hear you I think noise cancelling is kind of gravity. I can edit that line out Yeah Yeah, that's that's a good point. Like I don't know. Yeah, go ahead. That sounds great.
我……我看到过一些关于真实犯罪类节目因为心理健康问题而变得火爆的文章，因为真实犯罪主要由女性消费，我也看很多真实犯罪。所以这不完全正确，但我认为确实是女性在推动它的消费。但这似乎确实是一种经常提及心理健康的方式。是的，我和客户谈过这个。我个人注意到一个趋势，我的很多创伤受害者真的很喜欢所有那些真实犯罪和连环杀手的内容。这确实让我感同身受。所以这很有趣。他们总是说：“我希望我不是个坏人”之类的。
I like I I've seen like a couple of write ups on like true crime is getting big because of mental health issues like true crime is consumed primarily by women, which like I watch a lot of true crime too. So that's not, you know not entirely true, but I think it is kind of women that drive the consumption of it. But it does seem like a way that mental health gets brought up a lot. Yeah, I've talked about it with clients. I personally noticed a trend of a lot of my trauma victims really like all the true crime and serial killer stuff. And that's for sure I relate to it. So it's kind of interesting. And they're always like, I hope I'm not a bad person or something.
就像是，不，你只是在某种程度上试图掌控发生在你身上的事情。这可能是一种更安全的方式，因为很多与创伤患者相关的积极和消极行为，就像人们回到一个环境中试图掌握它一样。我的意思是，你看到它对人们产生影响的好方法或坏方法了吗？
It's like, no, you're just trying to get control of what happened to you on some level. It may be a safer way of doing that kind of, because a lot of the, I mean, positive and negative behaviors associated with trauma patients are like people going back into an environment to try and get mastery over it. And I mean, do you see good ways or bad ways that it affects people?
我的意思是，如果你正处于创伤中，看那些东西可能会触发创伤。就像我当时处于创伤中时，我无法接触那些。但后来那成了我能讽刺地观看的第一批内容之一。但我认为，是的，我认为它确实能帮上忙。而且我认为最近出来的大部分内容，可能遵循了认识到虐待动态心理学的趋势。
I mean, certainly if you're in trauma, like watching that stuff can be triggering. Like when I was a tide of traumas, like I couldn't go there. But then that was one of the first things that kind of came back as content that I can actually like ironically watch. But I think that, yeah, I think, I think it can help a lot. And a lot of the content, I think, coming out recently is following maybe the trend of recognizing the psychology of the abuse dynamic.
是的，心理暴力不仅仅是那样。关于 Gabby Petito 案件的纪录片。女性对此感同身受。我不知道你们是否……我的意思是，但在一个……她……你们知道我在说什么吗？是的。我不熟悉那个。那个房车女士或房车情侣，是吗？
Yeah, the psychological violence are more than that. The documentaries about the Gabby Petito case. And it's just like women relate to that so much. I don't know if you all, I mean, but it's in a, like in a, she's, do y'all know what I'm talking about? Yeah. I'm not familiar with that one. The van lady or the van couple, is that right?
是的，她大概 20 岁，我的意思是年轻的 20 多岁，我可能会说错，但是的，她当时正要去进行一次社交媒体之旅。是的，我不知道 Netflix。那太棒了。是的，还有一个新的。是的，是的，所以是一个 20 多岁的女孩，有点像创意型人才，试图拥抱世界，然后她被这个非常具有控制欲的施虐者吞噬了，但她发布了所有这些社交媒体内容，看起来一切都很完美，但……
Yeah, she was, she's like 20, I mean, young 20s or something, I'm gonna get it wrong, but yeah, she was like off to do like a social media tour Yeah, I did don't know Netflix. That was awesome. Yeah, and there's two there's a new one Yeah, yeah, so it's a young 20s girl who kind of gets like creative type who's Kind of trying to embrace the world and then she gets consumed by this like very controlling Abuser but was putting out like all this social media content that seemed like everything was perfect but
她实际上被他隔离在这辆房车里，在所有这些非常偏远的地方旅行，他在后台对她有暴力行为，诸如此类。但确实有很多那种内容，我想……我不知道，我的意思是，我觉得很着迷。是的，那可能……或者把它们放在一起，电视、电影，甚至真实犯罪本身，可能成为一个有趣的话题。是的，还有那种成分，就像你说的，这是一种安全的处理方式，就像你可以处理的焦虑，或者，你知道，那种伴随着创伤和受害感而来的多巴胺快感。这就像你可以在一个安全的方式下接触到它，你知道一切都会好起来的，即使在观看的时候，你也会没事的。
she was really isolated with him in this van traveling in all these really remote places and he was like violent with her in the background kind of thing and but yeah there's a lot of kind of that kind of content that I think I I don't know, I mean, I find it fascinating. Yeah, that may make a or either those together, TV, movies, and then even True Crime itself may make it like a fun kind of episode. Yeah, and kind of the component of like how what you're saying, like it's a safe way of processing, like it being like just the anxiety that you can process like, or, you know, kind of like the high that like dopamine high that comes with like the trauma and like victimization and stuff. It's like you can access that in a safe way though, where you like, know it's all going to be okay, like you're going to be okay, even in spite of people watching.
是的，是的。我也认为，在美国有一种名人文化，当人们说“哦，这个名人很有名、很漂亮，他们和我经历了同样的事情”时，这对于美国人来说有一种安慰感。我不知道。这听起来是一个富有成效的话题。James，你有一个……你提到了几个，比如瑜伽呼吸那一集。James 想让 Alice 带我们做一些……你知道的，你们在万物有灵论（Animism）上做过不少内容。嗯，但我喜欢那个话题，但我当时在笑，因为我猜这有点关于龙的女性能量。所以你想让 James 再一次进入新时代的东西。是这样吗？我被告知要问 Alice 关于龙的问题。我的意思是，我可以去聊那个。所以你的一个客户让你问 Alice 关于女性龙能量的问题。是这样吗？
Yeah, yeah. I think, too, like there's such a celebrity culture in America that just when people are like, oh, this celebrity is famous and beautiful and they have the same thing happened to me to them as me that there's something about that that is comforting to like Americans specifically. I don't know. That sounds like a fruitful topic. James, you got you got one that you got me thing that you floated a couple like the yoga breathing episode. James wants Alice to lead us in some like a big, you know, and we y'all done some stuff on animism a good bit. Um, but I like that topic, but I was laughing because I guess a little bit regarding as dragon female energy. So you want to get James once again to the new age stuff. Is that, I was told to ask, I was told to ask Alice about dragon. I mean, I can go there. So a client of yours asked you to ask Alice about female dragon energy. Is that right?
澄清一下。我当时在查它，在谷歌上我还是很困惑。那是女性的龙能量，还是雌性龙？你不会理解的。你就是不会理解的。你就是不会理解的。嗯，这……所以这就像是能量。这就像是一种原型能量，这是……而且有很多人对这种能量有不同的关系。但这基本上是这种想法，我的意思是，它有点像凤凰的类比，对我来说，龙就像是一种转化，你的龙能量就像是创伤……
Just to clarify. I was looking it up and I'm still confused on Google. Is that the dragon energy of the female or female dragons? You're not going to understand it. You're just not going to understand it. understand it. You're just not gonna understand it. Um, it this. So this is this is like the energy. It's like this archetypal energy of this is how and there are a lot of people who have different relationships with this energy. But it's basically this idea of kind of, I mean, it's sort of a little like a Phoenix kind of analogy where it's a direct like a to me a dragon is like a trans, like your dragon energy is like the trauma
你将其转化为你的力量。所以这就像是……本来会是那种爬行动物导向的，就大脑反应而言，你的一部分变成了你的力量。所以有一种神圣女性的理念，认为这是一种长期处于压迫之下的能量，它正以“龙能量”的形式显现出来。所以这就是联系所在。然后不同的人……
that you've transmuted into kind of your power. So it's like this really like what would otherwise be this kind of like reptilian like oriented like in terms of like how your brain reacts, part of your part of you becomes like your power. And so there's this feminine like divine feminine idea of like that's sort of this energy that's been in, you know, in oppression for a long time and it's coming out as like dragon energy. And so that's like sort of where the where the connection is. And then different people
与特定的龙建立联系。所以，你可以接受它，但我认为这就是它的意义所在，也许在最……我认为这是赋能，你所谈论的是赋能的东西。但绝对是冷门话题。但我认为如果它是冷门话题，通常我认为你就在那儿了。我很乐意花一整小时聊龙能量。我笑不是因为它听起来很疯狂。
connect with maybe like particular dragons. So there's, you know, you can take it, but that's like what I think is what that's about maybe and in the most like, you know, I think it's empowering is what empowering stuff is what you're talking about. But definitely off the beaten path. But I think if it's off the beaten path and that generally I think you're there. I would love a whole hour old dragon energy. I'm not laughing because it sounds crazy.
我笑是因为我能看出它在哪里是有力量的，思考那个以及背后的美。我们认为龙是丑陋的，就像我想到《霍比特人》里山中金子上的史矛革。他是一条很漂亮的龙，但有很多东西，很多意义，很多……更像是“唤醒女性龙”。等等，我不是《权力的游戏》的忠实粉丝，但我脑海中浮现的是丹妮莉丝和她的龙那种氛围。
I'm laughing because I could see where it is powerful and thinking about that and the beauty behind that. We think this is ugly dragon, like I was thinking of Shmaug in the mountains gold. He's a really pretty dragon, but there's a schmuck you know in the mountains gold and but it's really he's a really pretty dragon but there's a lot of things there a lot of meaning a lot of yeah sort of more like wake up the female dragon wait it uh can I'm not a big game of thrones person but I picture it's more of like a Daenerys with her dragons kind of vibe.
哦，龙的游戏。然后忽略……我不记得最后发生了什么，但有些事。你读过……当龙死去的时候。你读过爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger）或埃里希·诺伊曼（Erich Neumann）吗？那些后荣格学派的人？我没有，读得不多。不。很多关于人类学的东西，我的意思是读埃里希·诺伊曼读得不多。不，很多关于人类学的东西。我的意思是，读爱德华……读埃里希·诺伊曼是一件苦差事。
Oh, the game of dragons. And then ignore, like, I can't remember what happens at the end of that, but something. You ever read... When the dragons die and things. Have you ever read Edward Eddinger or Eric Neumann, the like kind of post-Yogium guys? I have not, not a lot. No. A lot of the anthropology, I mean reading Edwin, reading Eric Neumann not a lot. No, a lot of them a lot of the anthropology. I mean, reading Edward reading Eric Neumann is a slog.
再说一次，Lee 曾经听我听过一次有声书。当时是：“这到底是什么？”因为他们……你必须查阅所有这些过时的语言。他谈论了很长时间的“衔尾蛇式乱伦”之类的东西，这与实际的乱伦无关。这就像是自我与自我的重聚。对。无论如何，你必须熟悉非常过时的生物学才能理解他的隐喻。但他正在做的一件事，就像很多东西的来源一样，当你听到乔丹·彼得森（Jordan Peterson）谈论……
Again, Lee heard me listening to an audio book one time. It was like, what on the what in the world? Because they like you have to like look up all of this dated language. Like he talks about like oreboric incest and all this stuff for a long time, which doesn't have anything to do with actual incest. It's like the self rejoining the self. Right. Whatever you have to be familiar with like very outdated biology to understand his metaphors. But one of the things that he's doing with like the where a lot of that stuff comes from, like when you hear Jordan
你必须杀死你的龙并驾驭它。他甚至并不真正了解他的来源。他只是在 90 年代的加拿大荣格圈子里吸收了这些东西。那些后荣格学派的人中，有一种文化观点认为，在文明之前存在一种女性的、母系氏族的文化。然后随着城市的发展，它变成了更多的父权制，并且之前存在一种女神崇拜，这在很长一段时间里被认为是被推翻了。而现在这在现代考古学中又开始回归了。
Peterson talking about like, you have to slay your dragon and write it. And he doesn't even really know his sources. He just sort of absorbed this stuff in the Jungian circles in Canada in the nineties. Like there was some of those post Jungian guys, there's this idea that in culture that there was like a female, like a matriarchal culture before civilization. And then as cities developed, it became like a more of a patriarchy and that there was a goddess cult beforehand where you get like, which like for a long while they thought all of that was like disproven. And now that's kind of coming back into modern archeology.
就像多瑙河文化和所有这些原始神话文明一样，他们说有一种母性事物，女性和生育，尤其是非常丰满的女性被大量描绘。所以我们认为他们是……是的，大块头的女性能够生更多的孩子。这就是文明的重点。
Like with the multiburate culture and all of these kind of like proto-mythological civilizations, they're saying like, there was this maternal thing where women and birthing and like especially very heavy women are depicted a lot. So we think that they were like, yeah, big women are able to do more babies. This is the point of civilization.
然后当你有城市时，它被一种国王和祭司阶层所取代。所以他谈论的很多东西都反映在神话中。比如巴比伦神话中你有提亚马特（Tiamat），那是一条巨大的龙女神，然后男性英雄出去杀死了那个女神并建立了文明。这发生在埃及，或者所有这些地方，诺伊曼所说的是，那种母性女神崇拜正被描述为被城市结构和早期社会的英雄神话所推翻。所以，很多……他们认为这很糟糕，它失去了平衡，我们需要一种男性和女性、主动和被动的原则，而仅仅由英雄神话和历史上的“伟人理论”统治的社会注定会失败，因为它没有……
And then that is replaced by kind of like a king and priest class when you get cities. And so a lot of what he talks about is that that's reflected in mythology. So like Babylonian mythology that you have Tiamat, that it's this big dragon goddess, and then the male hero goes out and kills that goddess and builds civilization. And it happens in Egyptian or like all of it is what they were saying, what Neumann is saying is that that maternal like goddess cult is being described as being overthrown by the city structure and these hero myths of the early society. And so like a lot of, and they thought it was bad, it was out of balance that we needed sort of a masculine and a feminine and an active and a passive principle and just a society governed by the hero myth and the great man theory of history was doomed to fail because it had no, it was
太傲慢了，没有谦逊，对可持续性也没有持续的兴趣。我认为这就是为什么人们现在被那种东西吸引的原因，因为很多事情可能确实如此。而且你知道，世界面临的问题正使他们回归到那种状态。所以当你听到神圣女性和驾驭那条龙时，我认为这就是学术来源，但大多数在网上谈论这些的人，我不认为他们真的了解历史或来源。他们只是……这是一个吸引人的想法，你不需要（了解）。我的意思是，永恒哲学，说来话长。我的意思是，你可以接受或拒绝它，但很多有超感官天赋的人，会独立地引导这些东西。所以也有一个成分是……
too hebristic and had no humility and had no sustained interest in sustainability which I think that's why people are gravitating to that kind of thing now is that a lot of those things are probably true and You know the problems that the world is facing is making them kind of go back to that So when you hear about the divine feminine and like the writing that dragon a lot of those things I think that's where the scholarships coming from but most of the people talking that stuff online, I don't think really know the history or the sources. They're just, it's an appealing idea, which you don't have to. I mean, perennial philosophy, long story. I mean, you can take it or leave it, but a lot of people with extrasensory, you know, gifts, like channel this stuff themselves, like independently. So there's also also, there's a component of there are,
就像我说的，你可以接受或拒绝它，但我只是……这里有一个整体，有点像……这就是龙能量，当你谈论那种对旧母系社会和旧方式的揭示时，所有这些都像是一种集体能量力，就像那种龙能量进入集体，揭示那些旧的母系方式……
and like I said, you can like take it or leave it, but I'll just like, there's a whole, there's kind of like, this is where the dragon energy, when you're talking about kind of the uncovering of like that, the old matriarchies and the old ways, like that all coming is like this collective energy force of like that dragon energy coming into the collective of like uncovering like that old matriarchal ways
并像塔楼时刻一样崩溃，所有神圣的男性，像受限制的公司、结构、社会和虐待性的东西。是的，不，我能看出为什么那会是一个非常有帮助的神话框架。我的意思是，你遇到的情况和你处理所有深度心理学和永恒哲学时遇到的一样……
and like collapsing like in a tower moment, like all the divine masculine, like constricted corporations and structures and society and abusive stuff. Yeah, no, I can see why that would be like a very helpful kind of mythological framework. And I mean, you bump into the same thing that you do with like all depth psychology and perennial philosophy
就是那些互不认识的人继续独立地发现这些东西。那么这是它的证据基础吗？你知道，原型之类的，你知道，人们已经有很长时间了。是的，这就是我想要表达的。我对此非常感兴趣，因为在某种程度上，如果你真的对这个随机的小众领域感兴趣，并且来自科学背景，你开始意识到……
is it's like people who don't know each other continue to discover this stuff independently. So is that an evidence basis for it? You know, archetypes or something, you know, people have that for a long time. Yeah, that's kind of what I'm getting at. And I'm very interested in it because there's a certain level, like, if you're actually interested in, in like this random niche and come from a scientific background, you start realizing, like,
统计数据并不能真正解释为什么会有所有这些不同的人提出平行和相似的东西。所以这里有一个成分，我对意识非常感兴趣，你知道，当谈到心理学时，意识就像是心理学可能正在走向的前沿，在我看来。所以它与所有这些交叉。但斯蒂芬妮，意识是这个播客大部分的内容。但是，是的，我认为很多更直觉、更有同理心、想要将这些东西作为个人神话来参与的人，我认为他们不太愿意去了解这些思想的历史，因为其中很多是老男人、白人写的。
the statistics don't really make sense as to why there are all these disparate people coming up with sort of like parallel and similar stuff. So there's there's a component there like where I'm very interested in consciousness, you know when it comes to psychology like consciousness is like kind of the cutting edge of like maybe where psychology is going in my mind, but So it kind of intersects with all that What Stephanie consciousness is the majority of what this podcast is about. But the yeah, like I think that's a lot of people who are more kind of intuitive and like empathic and want to engage with that stuff as like their personal myth. I think are less reticent to learn the history of those ideas because because a lot of them are old men, white men writing about them.
但在我看来，去了解它的一个论点是，它确实给了你一个基础和证据来说：“好吧，如果匈牙利的白色兄弟会提出了……”（那是他的名字，与白人无关），而且所有这些不同的神秘主义者都提出了相同的想法，并且没有互动，那么这难道不给你一种框架吗……
But like an argument in my mind to do that is, it actually does give you a basis and evidence to say, well, if the white brotherhood in Hungary is coming up with, which that's his name, it has nothing to do with being white, and all of these different mystical people are coming up with these same ideas and there's no interaction, then doesn't that give you sort of a framework
将它们视为更心理学的思想，这些思想不可避免地会被人类发现，而不是我们需要争论其真实性的思想，如果它们在 2000 年来一直相当一致地出现的话。但是……但也许正是这些信息我们需要争论其真实性，你知道，如果它们在 2000 年来一直相当一致地出现的话。是的，但也许正是这些信息，我们在不同的意识水平上获取。是的，大脑中显示为爬行动物的许多区域也是爬行动物大脑的一部分，你知道，这很有趣。正是如此，正是如此。这就是……是的，我认为这就是我们到达……
to see them as more psychological ideas that are inevitably gonna be discovered by humans and not just ideas that we need to fight about the veracity of them, if they've come up for 2,000 years fairly consistently. But- But maybe it's this information that we need to fight about the veracity of them, you know, if they've come up for 2000 years fairly consistently. Yeah, but maybe it's this information that we're accessing at a different level of consciousness. Yeah, and a lot of those regions of the brain that show up as reptiles are like the part of the reptile brain too, you know, which is sort of an interesting. Exactly, exactly. And that's where yeah, and I think that's where we get to like,
我们可以谈谈，我们可以在某个时候谈谈自恋，以及我认为它就像爬行动物大脑。让我们做龙，让我们做龙那一集，这听起来不错。我想谈谈顶眼（parietal eye），我们从爬行动物祖先那里得到的小脑结构，龙……是的，可能是龙，但蜥蜴和鲨鱼有清晰的鳞片。我可以……我可以开龙的玩笑吗？是的，是的，请便。你可以。我不会在这里做。好的。我们不是万物有灵论者。
we could talk, we could talk at some point about like narcissism and like how I think it's like the reptile reptile brain and let's do dragons let's do dragon episode this sounds good I want to talk about the parietal eye the little brain structure we get from our reptilian ancestry where dragons yeah probably dragons but lizards and sharks have like a clear scale can I I just make dragon jokes? Yeah, yeah, please. You can. I'm not going to do them here. OK. We're not animus.
一些疯狂的龙笑话。所有的龙都在离开听众。为了澄清，我确实想知道，你如何开始那段对话……关于龙？嗯，是的，但我的意思是，就像……“嘿，还记得我的龙能量吗？”就像如果我在寻找它，或者如果我……你知道，如果我感兴趣并好奇，我该怎么办？
Some crazy dragon jokes. All the dragons are leaving the audience. For clarification, I do want to know, like, how do you start that conversation with... About dragons? Well, yeah, but I mean, just kind of like, yeah, remember my dragon energy? Like how do I go if I'm looking for that or if I'm, you know, if I'm interested and curious, you know, what do I do?
你是怎么了解它的？是的。我认为绝对地，你知道，冥想，老实说，如果你在上面冥想很多。这就是你达到那些更高意识水平的地方。这些东西会被下载到你身上。但有一群人谈论它。Kaya Ra 是一位我非常喜欢的精神导师，她谈论龙能量，但我不知道，它非常非常偏向神圣女性。所以我不太确定我会……我会考虑一下。好的研究在哪里？
How you kind of learn about it? Yeah. I think definitely, you know, meditation, honestly, like if you meditate a lot on it. And that's where it's like you kind of hit those higher levels of consciousness. And this stuff kind of gets downloaded into you. But there are a bunch of people who talk about it. Kaya Ra is a spiritual kind of teacher that I really like who talks about, who talks about dragon energy, but I don't know, it's very, very divine feminine oriented. So I'm not sure that I would. I'll think about it. Where's where's the good research?
当我想到你必须和一个灵媒交谈时。是的，好吧。进入这些东西有多种途径。我认为像两个方向，我的意思是，有非常形而上的个人，你知道，你只是清空你的大脑，事情就会被下载到你身上，但也有很多关于人类学、考古学和其他东西，就像有……你知道，我不认为这些东西是矛盾的，但……似乎关于它的媒体让你必须选择一边。我不知道。
When I think you have to talk to a psychic. Yeah, okay. Well, there's ways into this stuff. I think like both directions I mean, there's very metaphysical personal, you know You just emptying your brain and things are kind of downloaded into you but there's also like a lot of kind of anthropology and archaeology and other stuff too, like there's you know, I don't see those things in tension, but It seems like a lot of the media about that makes you sort of pick a side. I don't know.
对。不应该。是的。好吧，这可以被视为“龙工作”，你知道，就像“阴影工作”。但只是想……我的意思是，这是一种……你绝对可以把它用作一种阴影工作。你知道，如果它是某种我未必会……我的意思是，是的。如果它是某种我未必会……
Right. It shouldn't. Yeah. Well, this can be considered like dragon work, you know, like shadow work. But just wanted to. I mean, it's a type of you could definitely use it as a type of shadow work. You know, if it's something that I wouldn't necessarily like. I mean, yeah. If it's something that I wouldn't necessarily like,
我的意思是，是的，所以……龙工作就像阴影工作，有点接触到那些让你从创伤中获得力量的东西。它有点变成就像你交的一个朋友，那是你身后的力量源泉。而且这种能量，这种能量的味道，你可以感觉到，当你真正处于那种状态时，在你……这种能量，这种能量的味道，你可以感觉到，你知道，当你真正处于那种状态时，在你转化了一个创伤之后，就像真正从……
I mean, yeah, so yeah, dragon work is like shadow work, kind of getting in touch with that which kind of empowers you out of your trauma. And it sort of just becomes like almost this kind of like friend that you make, that's like your power source that's behind you. And kind of this energy, this flavor of energy that you can feel like, when you're really in that, after you've like kind of this energy, this flavor of energy that you can feel like, you know, when you're really in that, after you've like transmuted a trauma, like really healed from
它中治愈并整合了它，它不会就这样消失，你会有这种力量，就像在那里，这是一种与你以前拥有的不同味道的能量。所以它有点像那种龙能量，就像你转化它并使它成为你的力量。嗯，是的。而且……嗯，是什么？有很多像方法诗学，嗯，像 80 年代的荣格男性运动，嗯……
it and integrated it, there's like, it doesn't just go away, you kind of have this like strength that's like there, that's a different flavor of energy than you've had before. So it's kind of like that almost is like that dragon energy where it's like you kind of transmuted and make it into your power Um, yeah And um, what is it? There's a lot of like method poetic, um, like yungi and men's movements in the 80s that um
有时像被批评为父权制之类的。但大多数人，如果你看看他们，人们真的有点像“男人在 80 年代变得有毒和糟糕”，罗伯特·摩尔（Robert Moore）和布莱恩（Bly），很多人在吃那些。我认为我们是在试图以某种方式治疗 PTSD，当时生物医学模型在精神病学中处于顶峰。而且那里有很多东西，我认为也可以适用于男性，关于意识到你必须放弃控制才能拥有控制。罗伯特·摩尔有很多关于驾驭龙的书，将其作为一种个体化的任务。
Sometimes like we're criticized as being like patriarchal or whatever But most of them like if you look at them The people were really kind of like men are getting toxic and bad in the 80s and Robert Moore and blind, a lot of people eating those. I think we're trying to sort of like basically treat PTSD in ways when the biomedical model was sort of at its height in psychiatry. And there's a lot of stuff there too that I think also can apply to men about like realizing that you sort of have to give up control to have control. And Robert Moore's got a lot of books on writing a dragon as kind of like this task of individuation.
但我的意思是，最终在它的基础上，就像我们谈论的很多事情一样，你正在学习将你的直觉与你的创伤区分开来，因为它们来自大脑的同一个地方，而且很容易把一个误认为是另一个。它们感觉就像这种皮层下的能量，可以占据你，你知道，如果你没有与它建立更好的关系的话。是的，我也应该说，当我在谈论神圣女性能量时，我确实是在引用那种……那种存在于每个人身上的神圣女性能量，无论你的性别或生理性别如何。所以它就像每个人身上的那种，你们两个身上也是，那种神圣女性能量就像是……就像你们的女性龙也在觉醒。所以，哦，不。
But I mean, ultimately at the base of that, like a lot of things we talk about, you're learning to tell your intuition from your trauma because they come from the same place of the brain and they're easy to mistake one for the other. They feel like this kind of subcortical energy that can possess you, you know, if you don't have a better relationship to it. Yeah, I should, I should too say that, like, when I'm talking about divine feminine energy, I do, I am referencing like that, like the divine feminine energy that's like present in everybody, like, no matter your gender or your sex. And so it's like that in everybody in the two of you as well like that divine feminine energy is like is like your your feminine dragons are up are awakening too. So oh no.
或者是的。是的。但是，在集体中，你知道，它不仅仅是在女性中，但它赋予力量……我的意思是，它当然是，而且女性是……你知道，我们所谈论的原型。所以很有趣，就像奇幻文学对龙有这种痴迷，但它们也从情节的角度创造了一个问题，就像你不能真正用它们做任何事。《指环王》在《霍比特人》之后就缺少了龙，因为如果你有一条龙，它会让整场战斗变得毫无意义，你知道吗？
Or yes. Yes. But and in the collective you know it's not just it's not just among women but it empowers I mean it's certainly and like that's women are the art type of, you know, what we're talking about. So it's interesting to like fantasy has this like obsession with dragons, but they also create this problem just from like a plot perspective of like you can't really do anything with them. Like Lord of the Rings is missing the dragon after the Hobbit, because if you have a dragon, it just makes like the whole battle pointless, you know?
就像《权力的游戏》有点遇到了那个问题。就像他必须重写关于史矛革的一些东西，或者他说：“好吧，甘道夫实际上想让他们摆脱史矛革，因为它是最后一条龙，他不想让阴影得到它”之类的。他必须想出一个理由，为什么龙不能参与那种大事。而且我的意思是，《权力的游戏》有点那个问题……
Like Game of Thrones sort of hits that problem. Like he has to like retcon something about smog, or he's like, well, Gandalf actually wanted them to get rid of smog, because it was like the last dragon and he didn't want the shadow to get it or something. Like he has to come up with a reason why dragons can't participate in like the big thing. And I mean, like Game of Thrones kind of has that problem
他们就像试图控制军队，像得到……文艺复兴时代的剑之类的。然后龙就像一架 F-16，它就是。一旦你有了龙，什么都不重要了。所以 James，你在谈论万物有灵论。你有一个播客，我们做过关于仪式和万物有灵论的区别，以及仪式魔法类型。是的，我想那是几个月前，对吧？我想是的。我不知道。
where they're like trying to wrangle armies and like get, you know, re Renaissance era like swords and stuff. And then the dragon is just like an F 16 like it is. It doesn't nothing matters really. Once you have the dragon. So James, you're talking about animism. You have a podcast we did them on the difference in ritual and animism and kind of ritual magic type. Yeah, I think that was a couple months ago, right? I think so. I don't know.
时间。是的。我只是接入祖先层面，然后我不记得了，你知道，大部分剧集，因为那是凌晨两点，我精疲力竭。不，这只是我感兴趣的东西，只是回归到那个。我认为当我们想到万物有灵论时，有很多好的东西，更多的是一种……我不是说那是你在说的，我在问。嗯，有点。是的。然后就像，整个……嗯，我想……我迷失在那里了。我迷失了，但你……你走在了我正在想的道路上，肯定的。你是怎么遇到它的？
Time. Yeah. I just tap into the ancestral plane and then I don't remember, you know, most of the episodes because it's two in the morning and I'm exhausted. No, it's just something I'm interested in and just kind of getting back to that. I think there's a lot of good things that we think about when we think about animism, the more of a, I'm not saying that's what you're saying, I'm asking. Well, kind of. Yeah. And then like the, the whole, uh, I think, uh, I lost there. I'm lost, but you, you kind of, you're going down the path that I was thinking about, for sure. Where, how did you encounter it?
或者你在想什么？呃，实际上，我有几个客户对它非常感兴趣。嗯，我问那是个人宗教实践还是仅仅作为一个概念？作为一个概念，两者都有。所以它交叉到我谈论密宗瑜伽或密宗，它邀请你看到你世界中的一切都是神圣的，就像可以成为与神圣连接的一种方式，就像有形的东西，而许多精神视角和/或哲学视角更偏向禁欲主义，让你与一切断开连接。密宗是一种……是这些连接……
Or what were you thinking? Uh, actually, uh, I have a couple of clients that are just very interested in it. Um, and I'm like, is that like a personal religious practice or just like as a concept as a concept and kind of both. And so crosses over until I talk into tantric yoga or tantra, which like invites you to see everything in your world as like divine, like can be a way to connect with the divine, like tangible stuff, whereas a lot of like spiritual perspectives and or philosophical perspectives kind of are more aesthetic and get you to disconnect from everything. Tantra kind of is one of is one of these that kind of like connects
你与物质的东西。但是，是的，万物有灵论是……是的，非常符合同样的路线，我想……我想是的，对。当你想到万物有灵论那一集时，你在心理治疗中想到的想法是什么，或者你在看什么，James？我只是在想如何构建一集万物有灵论，或者那会……我的意思是，看看我的笔记。它有点像……那种信仰的调和，以及……
you with the physical stuff. And but yeah, animism is yeah, very kind of along those same lines, I think I think yeah, right What are the ideas that are coming up for you in therapy or that you're looking at james when you're thinking of like i'm just Trying to think of how to kind of structure an animism episode or what that would uh, I mean Going to my note. It's kind of like the um, kind of like reconciliation of faith and Like whether the christian god and but being able to see that God everywhere. Yeah, yeah.
就像基督教的上帝，但能够看到上帝无处不在。是的，是的。是的。然后休息，你知道，人们挣扎着……我那种调和的部分，那种调和的部分，他们失去了信仰，重新回到信仰中，但新的信仰更像是开放的。它就在这里，在我周围。但他们仍然看到并感受到上帝，他们以前看到的同一个上帝，但在不同的事物中。这是关于与此抗争。而且我认为这很整洁。而且它比仅仅与他们探索那个更深入。但它有点把那个带到他们的注意中，我不……他们感觉到
Yeah. And then rest, you know, people wrestling like I kind of that reconciliation piece like reconciliation piece where they lost faith coming back into faith, but the new faith is more of like open. It's here is around me. But that they still see that and feel that God, that same God that they saw before, but in different things. It's about wrestling with that. And I think it's pretty neat. And it goes deeper than kind of exploring that with them. But it's kind of bringing that to their attention that I don't, they feel
是的。然后是休息，你知道，人们在挣扎，就像我所说的那种和解的部分，那种失去信仰后又回归信仰的和解，但新的信仰更开放。它就在我周围。但他们仍然看到并感受到上帝，那个他们以前看到的同一位上帝，只是在不同的事物中。这就是关于与此挣扎的过程。我觉得这很棒。这比单纯与他们一起探索要深刻得多，但这更像是让他们意识到这一点，因为我不确定他们是否感觉到了。
guilty that they're outside of nature and just feel God and I'm like, in the in see God and everything and in people. And so they feel they wrestle with that. They wrestle with that like an easy feeling of like, can we do you know, can I just allow? Yeah, because like, you know, your God is a, you know, man God, you know, is he physical? Is he not? All those things. And so it's kind of like, again, they're seeing they're feeling this, the president of this God that they knew before lost faith, and then they get back, you know, that faith, but now it's more present in everything. And so it's confusing. That I remember in comparative religion school, really like kind of resisting that urge to put things into the categories of monotheism and polytheism when they were
因为他们觉得自己脱离了自然，只是感受到了上帝，而我却觉得在万物和每个人身上都能看到上帝。所以他们感到困惑，他们在挣扎，挣扎于一种简单的感觉，比如，我们能……你知道，我能顺其自然吗？是的，因为你知道，你的上帝是一个，你知道，人性的上帝，你知道，他是物质的吗？还是不是？所有这些问题。所以这有点像，他们再次感受到了这种上帝的存在，这种他们在失去信仰之前就认识的上帝，然后他们找回了那种信仰，但现在它更普遍地存在于一切事物中。所以这很令人困惑。我记得在比较宗教学学校时，我真的非常抗拒那种把事物归类为一神论和多神论的冲动，当他们
explaining that and I was just going through it like yeah but what religious tradition is alive where these things are as separate as you're trying to make them I mean there's you know Hinduism which most people would say is polytheistic some of the earliest Vedas are the guy going to ask the gods like how many gods are there really needs like 900 and then he's like then he's like, no, really, how many are there? And Vishnu is like, okay, fine, it's 30. And he's like, no, but really, how many are there? And he's like, it's five.
解释这一点时，我当时就在想，是的，但现在有什么宗教传统能把这些东西分得像你试图做的那样开呢？我的意思是，你知道印度教，大多数人会说它是多神论的，但一些最早的《吠陀》里，有人问神说，到底有多少位神？他说有900位，然后他说，不，真的，到底有多少位？毗湿奴说，好吧，好吧，是30位。他说，不，但真的，到底有多少位？他说，是5位。
And they just manifest as more as you need them. And he's like, no, really, how many are there? And it's like, there's one, it's just me. It's all me. You know? And then there's tons of, you know, Christian mystical traditions where you see other people, you know, finding like Gnosticism,
它们只是根据你的需要显现出来。他说，不，真的，到底有多少位？就像是，只有一位，就是我。全都是我。你知道吗？还有很多，你知道，基督教神秘主义传统，在那里你会看到其他人，你知道，发现像诺斯替教派，
you're finding like the spark of God and other people and like actualizing that by putting it together and building community. Like you can't do that alone. You're seeing the world is sort of alive and like the presence of God. So it's like, I don't know. I get that if you treat it like a country club
你发现像上帝的火花在其他人身上，并通过将其整合在一起并建立社区来实现这一点。就像你不能独自做到这一点。你看到世界是某种活生生的，就像上帝的存在。所以就像，我不知道。我明白如果你把它当作一个乡村俱乐部，
and you're like, I'm just gonna drive my chromed out SUV to the mega church and then I'm gonna go to the Cheesecake Factory and, and it's religion as a country club, like, yeah, okay. But when the tradition is actually participatory and sort of breathing, are those things ever separate in anything? I mean, I'm thinking of like the Aztec story where they all get they all get down to, like having started with a mystical tradition that
你就像，我要开着我那镀铬的SUV去大型教堂，然后我要去芝士蛋糕工厂，这就像把宗教当作一个乡村俱乐部，好吧，没问题。但当这种传统实际上是参与性的，并且在某种程度上是鲜活的时候，这些东西在任何事物中是分开的吗？我的意思是，我在想阿兹特克人的故事，他们最终都……从一个神秘主义传统开始，
Was based in this idea that we are all one and we are and you are God and we're all God Mm-hmm and then it then it gets taken over by like a structure of religion that kind of squelches that and it's like no you can't like actually like we can't With God we can't tell him that and like then And then the masculine structures come in and squelch it. But it starts with that kind of realization that people have had over time, like of that same kind of click that your individual clients are having, too,
基于这样一个理念：我们都是一体的，我们是，你就是上帝，我们都是上帝。嗯哼。然后它被一种宗教结构所接管，这种结构压制了这一点，就像是，不，你不能……实际上，我们不能……和上帝在一起，我们不能告诉他，然后……然后男性结构介入并压制了它。但它始于人们随着时间推移所拥有的那种实现，就像你的个人客户也拥有的那种顿悟，
of that click of like, whoa, we're one. And how does it feel walking around? What is the walking around effect of really living that? how does it feel walking around like what is it? What is the walking around effect of like really living that? What does it feel like? Well, and even Buddhism which is is pretty You know most traditions of Buddhism are pretty atheistic like they're skeptical even of consciousness and say it's this kind of illusion that has been Created but even they have this idea that like you see the divine in one spot intensely so that you can learn to see it everywhere. You know that is the point of the encounter and trying to what is it it may be apocryphal but I've read it a couple times there's that story where the Spanish conquistadors are
那种顿悟，就像，哇，我们是一体的。那走在路上是什么感觉？真正活出那种感觉的“行走效应”是什么？那是什么感觉？嗯，甚至佛教，它是相当……你知道，大多数佛教传统是相当无神论的，就像他们甚至对意识持怀疑态度，并说这是一种被创造出来的幻觉，但即使是他们也有这种想法，即你在一个地方强烈地看到神性，这样你就可以学会到处看到它。你知道，这就是相遇的意义，并试图……这是什么？这可能是伪经，但我读过几次，那个故事说西班牙征服者
like making the Aztec warriors like smash the temple and there's like the stone figures and they smash it and they're like yeah look your gods are gone you have to be Christian now and they're like these are just rocks. The gods have been dead forever. And the conchisters are like, what? Yeah, no, the moon god, this is just, these are pieces of her body. And chaos is always in this cycle. And we just have to sort of do these rituals
让阿兹特克战士砸碎神庙，那里有石像，他们砸碎了它，他们说，是的，看，你们的神没了，你们现在必须信基督教了，他们说，这些只是石头。神永远不会死。征服者说，什么？是的，不，月亮女神，这只是，这些是她身体的一部分。混乱总是处于这种循环中。我们只需要做这些仪式，
to remind ourselves that it works that way. And the Spaniards have no comprehension of that kind of cosmology. You know? Yeah. They were in a different realm of consciousness and it was kind of, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
提醒自己它是这样运作的。而西班牙人对那种宇宙观毫无理解。你知道吗？是的。他们处于不同的意识领域，这有点，是的。是的。是的。
They did have, they did have guns. A quick reminder that we do this podcast for free and there are significant expenses associated with it, including the biggest resource of my life right now, which is time. Um, one of the things that would really help us and hopefully would help you would be to check out one of our sponsors, Hardy Nutritionals. Hardy is a vitamin company that I never encountered the advertising of. We heard over and over again from multiple people with treatment-resistant anxiety
他们确实有枪。快速提醒一下，我们免费制作这个播客，并且与之相关的开支巨大，包括我现在生活中最大的资源，那就是时间。嗯，有一件事真的会帮助我们，也希望会帮助你，那就是看看我们的赞助商，Hardy Nutritionals。Hardy是一家我从未见过其广告的维生素公司。我们一次又一次地从多个患有难治性焦虑症的人那里听说，
and dopamine disorders like bipolar disorder and other things that they had tried everything and Hardy was what worked. And so I checked them out and they have really good research. I'm not a fan of a lot of the BS that's in the supplement and wellness space. Hardy paid for a lot of research on their product. And when I ordered some for myself, I saw a big difference in my life. And my wife made fun of me,
以及多巴胺紊乱，如双相情感障碍和其他疾病，他们尝试了一切，而Hardy是有效的。所以我去了解了一下，他们有非常好的研究。我不喜欢补充剂和健康领域里的很多废话。Hardy为他们的产品支付了大量的研究费用。当我为自己订购了一些时，我看到了我生活中巨大的变化。我妻子取笑我，
thought it was gonna be Alex Jones selling vitamins on the radio. And when she tried them, she really liked them too. There's a lot of data about how they can reduce the symptoms of ADHD without medications or lower your need for medication, also manage some of the effects of autism spectrum disorder and a whole lot of other things. Newer research around nutrition is saying that the synergistic effects of multiple things being planned to work together is a lot more effective than one thing working alone. You can get a lot of information about that on our website. Or you can head over to GetHardy, that's G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y and use offer code taproot for 15% off. It would help them, it would help me, and it also would probably help you.
以为会是亚历克斯·琼斯在广播里卖维生素。当她尝试了之后，她也非常喜欢它们。有很多数据表明它们可以在不使用药物的情况下减少多动症的症状，或者降低你对药物的需求，还可以管理一些自闭症谱系障碍的影响以及许多其他事情。关于营养的较新研究表明，多种事物协同作用的效果比单一事物单独作用要有效得多。你可以在我们的网站上获得很多关于这方面的信息。或者你可以前往GetHardy，即G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y，并使用优惠码taproot享受15%的折扣。这会帮助他们，会帮助我，也可能会帮助你。
One of the more frequent things that patients and people in the randomized controlled trials that Hardy conducted report is that they feel more themself, more focused and more effective at getting things done, which can result in all of us having a little bit more time. Yeah. Well, um.
Hardy进行的随机对照试验中，患者和人们报告的最常见的事情之一是，他们感觉更像自己，更专注，更有效地完成事情，这可能导致我们所有人多出一点时间。是的。嗯……
They didn't stop to ask. What other, what other stuff? What are their topics? You know, would be things that you kind of see like emergingly relevant or you just like want to say the profession. I mean, half the things that I write are just like, I'm angry that everybody at school said it worked this way and everybody else, you know, practices are structured this kind of traditional way.
他们没有停下来问。还有什么，还有什么东西？还有什么话题？你知道，会是你觉得那种新兴相关的，或者你只是想说这个职业。我的意思是，我写的一半东西只是因为，我很生气，学校里的每个人都说它是这样运作的，而其他人的做法都是以这种传统方式构建的。
And we're just like, No, it doesn't work that way. Like, we need to go back to a lot of the things that we used to know works better, that we forgot. And even if they're not popular. I don't know. I mean, some of the stuff that I write is it's really about other providers, not, you know, individuals, but just movements and psychology, you know, and the way we apply it clinically. and psychology and the way we apply it clinically. Any big topics or things you feel like would be helpful, James, like, yeah. Yeah, I'm just, well, obviously it's a lot of how, one of the biggest things is like,
而我们只是说，不，它不是那样运作的。我们需要回到很多我们过去知道效果更好，但我们忘记了的事情。即使它们不流行。我不知道。我的意思是，我写的一些东西，它确实是关于其他提供者的，而不是，你知道，个人，但只是心理学中的运动，你知道，以及我们临床应用它的方式。以及我们临床应用它的方式。有什么大的话题或你觉得会有帮助的事情吗，詹姆斯，比如，是的。是的，我只是，嗯，显然这很大程度上是关于如何，最大的事情之一是，
yeah, provider burnout is huge right now, whether it's mental health professionals, whether it's physicians, anything, a lot of people who are just providing a service to people. It's trying to get back to the basics of why, you know, why do we do this? What are we in the same path over and over again, as a profession, you know, we do the same things that people burn out before us have burnt out on and, you know, we see ourselves doing it, but how do we, you know, stay and how do we maintain? So kind of exploring that and what we do, what we can do. There's a lot of stuff on that. You know, I've been doing a lot of mindfulness
是的，提供者倦怠现在非常严重，无论是心理健康专业人士，还是医生，任何事情，很多只是为人们提供服务的人。这是试图回到我们为什么做这件事的基本点，你知道，为什么我们做这件事？我们作为一种职业，是否一次又一次地走在同一条道路上，你知道，我们做着那些在我们之前精疲力竭的人所做的事情，而且，你知道，我们看着自己这样做，但我们如何，你知道，留下来，我们如何维持？所以有点探索这一点以及我们做什么，我们可以做什么。关于这一点有很多东西。你知道，我一直在做很多正念
based stress reduction work with a lot of people that's been really effective in kind of showing them that you got to take back control of something and sometimes that's your body and um and that that kind of alleviates some of that that tension at work but a lot of these things are just around systems and organizations that can't change and that's the biggest thing as well and so it's kind of big relationship talks with inside their organization that helps with that trust but that that stuff is important to me and something I'd like to continue to discuss. A lot of James's practices about medical burnout, executive burnout, kind of helpers, healers, and decision makers, you know, the strain on them. That'd be interesting. Do you see much of that, Alice? I'm not sure your kind of client focus.
基础的减压工作，和很多人一起，这在向他们展示你必须重新控制某些东西方面非常有效，有时那是你的身体，嗯，那种工作中的紧张感在某种程度上减轻了一些，但很多这些事情只是围绕着无法改变的系统和组织，这也是最大的事情，所以这有点像在他们的组织内部进行大的关系谈话，这有助于建立信任，但那些东西对我来说很重要，也是我想继续讨论的事情。詹姆斯的很多做法是关于医疗倦怠、行政倦怠、那种帮助者、治疗者和决策者，你知道，他们身上的压力。那会很有趣。你对此了解多吗，爱丽丝？我不确定你那种客户关注点。
Also, I'm not sure your kind of client focus. Yeah, a little bit, a little bit for sure. And I think, but not as much like medical burnout per se. I do see other practitioners, though, so of counselors and social workers. So that stuff does come up. But I think it is, yeah, it's interesting, I think. I think it happens everywhere, but I mean, me and James both worked in a hospital
另外，我不确定你那种客户关注点。是的，有一点，肯定有一点。而且我认为，但不是那么多像医疗倦怠本身。不过，我确实看到了其他从业者，所以是咨询师和社会工作者。所以那些事情确实会出现。但我认为它是，是的，很有趣，我想。我认为它到处都在发生，但我的意思是，我和詹姆斯在做这个之前都在医院工作过。
before we did this. But the thing that I would see was like, they would do a talk or something, but they're like, this is the problem. Everybody knows it. We need to get back to this thing that is self-evidently good. And everyone would be like, yeah, we should do that.
但我会看到的事情是，他们会做一个演讲什么的，但他们说，这就是问题所在。每个人都知道。我们需要回到这个显而易见的好东西上来。每个人都会说，是的，我们应该那样做。
And then you'd go into these meetings and they're like, but the problem that they're all talking about is bureaucracy or the effect of bureaucracy, which sort of tries to, it does two things that I think are like evil and no, no exaggeration. Like I think are evil. Like one, it sort of deflects like all accountability so that no one is at fault. And you, you never can solve the problem because like everybody participated in a little bit Which I don't think is like a good structure and then like to like a lot of bureaucracy I think what it does is like it makes it to where you're taking things that are self-evident and then you're trying to find like empirical
然后你会进入这些会议，他们说，但他们都在谈论的问题是官僚主义或官僚主义的影响，它试图，它做了两件我认为是邪恶的事情，不，不夸张。就像我认为是邪恶的。第一，它在某种程度上转移了所有的责任，所以没有人有过错。而且你，你永远无法解决这个问题，因为每个人都参与了一点点，我认为这不是一个好的结构，然后，第二，很多官僚主义，我认为它所做的是，它使你采取那些显而易见的事情，然后你试图找到像经验性的
Structures to replicate them or to measure them and you can't't. Like the thing you're trying to do, like competence, you know, a lot of the time is just like not something you can have a checklist for. And what I would see a ton of time is like we'd have the meeting where they talk about the effect of over your, your bureaucratization of these things, and then be like, yeah, this is bad. So let's fix it. And everyone's like, yeah, and they agree and then when you But the only solution is more of the thing that did the problem like you can never just be like Hey, if we all know this is true. Can we just know it and move on? It was like no, but we had to prove it and have a checklist and a screener like that
结构来复制它们或衡量它们，但你做不到。就像你试图做的事情，比如能力，你知道，很多时候只是你不能有一个清单的东西。我看到很多次的情况是，我们会开会，他们谈论官僚主义对这些事情的影响，然后说，是的，这很糟糕。所以让我们修复它。每个人都说，是的，他们同意，然后当你……但唯一的解决方案是导致问题的那个东西的更多版本，你永远不能只是说，嘿，如果我们都知道这是真的。我们能只是知道它然后继续前进吗？就像是，不，但我们必须证明它，并有一个清单和一个筛选器，像那样
Look guys, this is just 65 questions to ask somebody to find out if they have anxiety and it was like I I know that Like I know if they have anxiety and it was like I I know that like I Anxiety and by question 30 they're gonna have a lot more, you know like you do you see that at all cuz that that's kind of what I Saw not I don't want to pick on health care because it's not just a health care thing I think it's a human thing. I mean we just talked about it in religion. So it's it's it's everywhere Yeah, well just an example. I had a massage on Friday. It was awesome. And, uh, but I was, you know, I kind of asked, how many, how many bodies do you see before you just have to call it quits in a day? And they're like, four. I'm like, four, you can give four massages and you're done like physically. But they're like, no, that's also mentally like, yeah, so it's, and then, but their, their capacity was at least, you know, like eight bodies a day or, you know, six bodies a day,
看，伙计们，这只是问某人65个问题来找出他们是否有焦虑，就像我……我知道，就像我知道他们是否有焦虑，就像我……我知道，就像我……焦虑，到第30个问题时，他们会有更多，你知道，就像你……你看到过吗？因为那有点像我看到的，我不想挑剔医疗保健，因为它不仅仅是医疗保健的事情，我认为这是人类的事情。我的意思是，我们刚才在宗教中谈到了它。所以它到处都是。是的，好吧，举个例子。我周五做了按摩。太棒了。而且，呃，但我，你知道，我有点问，在一天之内你必须放弃之前，你看了多少，多少个身体？他们说，四个。我说，四个，你可以做四个按摩，然后你就完成了，就像身体上。但他们说，不，那在精神上也一样，是的，所以它是，然后，但他们的，他们的容量至少是，你知道，像一天八个身体，或者，你知道，一天六个身体，
but it's gentle down to four. And I think that's what we do is, as professionals in this, right, is that we somehow pull back because we start listening to our bodies and our minds and we're like, we went from, and then we don't take a step back and how do we get from eight to four? You know, we do that and then But yeah, it's outside of the medical that's that's my point is this kind of it's anything that provides a service to someone and in some aspect We're finding the same thing over is how it's decreased capacity and that could be a lot of factors And some of those factors that definitely want to explore. Yeah, that's fascinating. I Don't know how she got a topic or anything that you feel like would make a good episode Hmm. I like this stuff. We're talking about
但它减少到了四个。我认为这就是我们作为这个领域的专业人士所做的，对吧，就是我们以某种方式退缩，因为我们开始倾听我们的身体和思想，我们就像，我们从，然后我们没有退后一步，我们如何从八个变成四个？你知道，我们那样做，然后……但是的，它在医疗之外，这就是我的观点，这是任何为某人提供服务的东西，在某种程度上，我们发现同样的事情是容量如何减少，这可能是很多因素。而其中一些因素确实想探索。是的，那太迷人了。我不知道她是怎么得到一个话题或任何你觉得会成为一个好剧集的东西。嗯。我喜欢这些东西。我们正在谈论
That's just Yeah, I'm trying to think trying to think what else I mean, I'm kind of we kind of hit on it Like I mean, I think a lot of stuff about like personality disorders and complex PTSD To me maybe I don't know I don't know how much we can get at like, you know I see complex PTSD as being like sort of more of a systemic issue yeah For I mean the arty lang thing of like it's a normal reaction to the world. It's like, yeah, you're it's not insane to be insane in an insane world. RD Lang stuff.
那只是……是的，我正在尝试思考，尝试思考还有什么。我的意思是，我有点……我们有点触及它。就像，我的意思是，我认为很多关于人格障碍和复杂创伤后应激障碍（CPTSD）的东西，对我来说，也许我不知道，我不知道我们能达到多少，你知道，我看待复杂创伤后应激障碍，更像是一个系统性问题。是的，为了……我的意思是，RD·莱恩（RD Laing）说的，这是对世界的正常反应。就像，是的，在一个疯狂的世界里变得疯狂并不疯狂。RD·莱恩的东西。
Right. And then I think a lot and then I think a lot of society is just walking around with this baked in trauma from just like how our society is built in and having to and this is like where people feel like they have to like fit into these boxes and molds and do things in disparate particular ways, and that's burning people out. You know, it's like that. But yeah. So I don't know, stuff like that, I think is really where my head's at a lot of the time, I'm trying to think what else. Yeah. What about you? Yeah. How do you see that in your practice? Like the, um, the, just the kind of, cause I see people who come in and they all feel like they're universally not able to deal with something that's just like bad and overwhelming and just being like,
对。然后我认为很多……然后我认为很多社会只是带着这种根深蒂固的创伤走来走去，仅仅是因为我们的社会是如何建立的，并且不得不……这就是人们觉得他们必须适应这些盒子和模具，并以不同的特定方式做事的地方，这正在让人们精疲力竭。你知道，就像那样。但是的。所以我不确定，像那样的东西，我认为确实是我大部分时间都在想的地方，我正在尝试思考还有什么。是的。你呢？是的。你在你的实践中是如何看待这一点的？就像，嗯，只是那种，因为我看到人们进来，他们都觉得他们普遍无法处理某种只是坏的和压倒性的事情，并且只是像，
no, I can't deal with that either. And I also talk to, you know, 20 people a week that are saying the same thing. So you're not alone with that. But there's something about the culture that makes us feel alone. Like if you're, if you're having an issue or you're having a problem, that it's not something that everyone else has had. And I think it is. A lot of that is. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, and I'll just say that to people. I mean, I think a lot of the people who seem to have it all together are actually the people that if you got inside their heads, you wouldn't want to be that person. I think they're all people who've had to just really, a lot of people who've had to really fit themselves
不，我也处理不了那个。而且我也和，你知道，每周20个人交谈，他们都在说同样的事情。所以你并不孤单。但文化中有些东西让我们感到孤独。就像如果你，如果你有一个问题，或者你有一个麻烦，那不是其他人都有过的东西。而且我认为它是。很多都是。是的。是的。我的意思是，我会对人们说。我的意思是，我认为很多看起来一切都处理得很好的人，实际上是那些如果你进入他们的头脑，你不会想成为那个人的人。我认为他们都是不得不真的，很多人不得不真的适应自己
into a particular box. And those are the people that a lot of people are kind of venerating or putting up on a pedestal. And it's like, those are the people that a lot of people are kind of venerating or putting up on a pedestal. And it's like, those are the people who are doing things in this certain way that like, if you do that, you're going to get completely burned out. Because it's somebody else's. It's just this very static way of being. Does that, yeah. Yeah. Show me a hero and I'll show you a tragedy, I think is the Fitzgerald line. The what about LLM's AI? I'd like to do one on that. The effects of that on I think when the I don't know if it sounds like you listen to that animism episode James a while ago, but one of the three lines in that ritual and animism episode
进入一个特定的盒子。而那些是很多人有点崇拜或放在基座上的人。而且就像，那些是很多人有点崇拜或放在基座上的人。而且就像，那些是以这种特定方式做事的人，就像，如果你那样做，你就会完全精疲力竭。因为那是别人的。这只是一种非常静态的存在方式。那是，是的。是的。给我一个英雄，我会给你一个悲剧，我想这是菲茨杰拉德的话。关于LLM（大语言模型）人工智能呢？我想做一个关于那个的。它对……的影响，我想当……我不知道这听起来像不像你听过那个万物有灵论的剧集，詹姆斯，很久以前，但那个仪式和万物有灵论剧集中的三行之一
that I did based on some of the qualitative stuff tracking the way psychosis shows up to the 50s, 60s, 70s and 80s. There's these like is like the brain has been relatively modern for a 50s, 60s, 70s and 80s. There's these like, the brain has been relatively modern for a long time, like about 2 million years it didn't change. Yeah. So the way that consciousness changed was around things like technology and culture, civilization, and then the unconscious being the sort of compensatory mechanism to help us balance all of the forces we don't notice but need as a counterbalance to whatever civilization has done to consciousness like in any era.
我根据一些定性资料做的，追踪精神病在50年代、60年代、70年代和80年代的表现方式。有这些……就像大脑在50年代、60年代、70年代和80年代相对现代。有这些……大脑在很长一段时间里相对现代，大约200万年它没有改变。是的。所以意识改变的方式是围绕技术和文化、文明等事物，然后潜意识是某种补偿机制，帮助我们平衡所有我们没有注意到但需要作为对文明对意识所做任何事情的平衡的力，就像在任何时代一样。
And a lot of the stuff in that episode is about how the metaphors that we can draw through technology change the way that we think about consciousness and ourself. Like there's that meme joke that made the rounds like a couple months ago where somebody was like, you know, like clocks are invented. And then the person's like, God is a clock, or, you know, or buildings are invented. And people are like, God is an architect.
而那一集中的很多东西是关于我们可以通过技术得出的隐喻如何改变我们思考意识和自我的方式。就像几个月前流传的那个模因笑话，有人说，你知道，就像时钟被发明了。然后那个人说，上帝是一个时钟，或者，你知道，或者建筑物被发明了。人们说，上帝是一位建筑师。
And then, you know, like whatever the internet is invented and people are like, oh, God is a network. Like, but there is something to that. And I think LLMs probably are going to, I'm not a huge fan and I think things like chat GPT will probably fall apart and take a chunk of the economy with them. I don't know if that, I don't know when that will happen.
然后，你知道，就像无论互联网被发明了，人们说，哦，上帝是一个网络。就像，但那确实有道理。而且我认为LLM可能将会，我不是一个超级粉丝，而且我认为像ChatGPT这样的东西可能会分崩离析并带走经济的一部分。我不知道那，我不知道那什么时候会发生。
But, and it may be not, but I just don't see like a ton of, you know, I'm not like an enthusiast kind of tech bro there, but I do think that something like that, just being a part of something that we will be interacting with every day in five years is inevitable. At this point, like we like it or not, like we all kind of have to rely on the latest thing. It's hard to unwind the clock.
但是，而且可能不会，但我只是没看到很多，你知道，我不是那种技术兄弟的狂热者，但我确实认为，像那样的事情，只是成为我们五年内每天都会与之互动的东西的一部分是不可避免的。在这一点上，就像我们喜欢与否，就像我们都必须依赖最新的东西。很难倒转时钟。
But I think that changes the way that we think about ourselves in ways that are important and sometimes nefarious, but also sometimes opportunities for interesting stuff. Like for example, you know, the AIs, they're not AIs. They're basically like search engines that just are predicting the next word in a sequence based on a very complicated algorithm. So that you're getting somebody who said something like what you're trying to say put into a blender
但我认为这改变了我们思考自己的方式，以重要且有时邪恶的方式，但也时而有有趣事物的机会。例如，你知道，人工智能，它们不是人工智能。它们基本上就像搜索引擎，只是根据一个非常复杂的算法预测序列中的下一个词。所以你得到的是一个说了类似你想说的话的人，被放进了一个搅拌机里
with a whole bunch of other data that's being marked as high quality. And one of the things that does I think is it really separates like what humans can do from what their calculators, basically. And I think that the one thing that's kind of good there is it's like all of the people who are really proud that they had all this information and ability to just regurgitate traditional hierarchical stuff, that isn't a skill that I think is useful. And now that LLMs can just do them in a second, I think that that maybe is a part of like
和一大堆其他被标记为高质量的数据。我认为它所做的一件事是，它确实将人类能做的事情与他们的计算器基本上分开了。而且我认为有一件事是好的，那就是，所有那些真正为自己拥有所有这些信息和能力来简单地复述传统等级制度的东西而感到自豪的人，那不是我认为有用的技能。而现在LLM可以在一秒钟内完成它们，我认为这也许是……的一部分
the structure of our culture that is being seen as like not human, as like a calculator, like not the point and that the intuition and the emotion and the ability to make connections that a computer can't make is maybe gonna be a little bit more celebrated. I'm trying to like find a ray of sunshine in the LLM thing But does that make sense? Like I don't know it seems like there's some places to go with that. Yeah
我们文化结构的一部分，被视为不像人类，像一个计算器，不像重点，而直觉、情感和建立计算机无法建立的联系的能力也许会受到更多的赞美。我正在尝试在LLM的事情中找到一线阳光。但这有意义吗？就像我不知道，看起来有一些地方可以去。是的
I was I've been guilty the last, you know week on that trend of Studio Ghibli Type cartoons from photos, you know and adding chat you see recreate some and I was in last week, you know, it melted kind of some of the chat GBTs like servers because people are just doing it often. But then I just, you know, it was kind of realized that like Miyazaki, you know,
我……我过去，你知道，一周在那个从照片中制作吉卜力工作室风格卡通的趋势上是有罪的，你知道，并添加聊天……你看到重新创造一些，我上周在，你知道，它融化了一些ChatGPT的服务器，因为人们只是经常这样做。但后来我只是，你知道，有点意识到，像宫崎骏，你知道，
founder, Stio Ghibli is just anti AI. It's like, it's take, it took a year for me to, you know, do this one scene, draw it out and animate it and then I don't I haven't seen what if he said anything recently about this trend, but you're just thinking about that of like Yeah, it's something so small just like recreating a photo It's kind of just counter to some by these core thought about the thing itself And now I feel bad about it Have you ever seen the clip of Miyazaki like going to the computer school like a couple years ago for like their thesis or whatever?
吉卜力工作室的创始人，只是反人工智能。就像，它花费，我花了一年时间来，你知道，做这一个场景，画出来并动画化它，然后我没有……我没看到如果他最近对这个趋势说了什么，但你只是在想那个，就像，是的，这只是一个小东西，就像重新创造一张照片，它有点只是违背了某些核心思想关于事物本身。现在我对此感到难过。你见过宫崎骏几年前去计算机学校看他们的论文什么的片段吗？
It's pretty it's pretty painful to watch because he tradition he's like very he's kind of a difficult guy and Won't comment on his own work and when he does it tends to be like kind of misdirection almost like yeah but there's like a clip where there's these PhD students at a Japanese technical university and they're like this algorithmically does whatever and they've made like some kind of zombie with no head but it's like walking with its legs or some there's walking with its like arms and it's like this mutant creature and there it's like for a video game from camera and they're all like really proud
看那个真的很痛苦，因为他传统上，他就像非常，他是一个有点困难的人，而且不会评论他自己的作品，当他这样做时，往往就像某种误导，几乎就像，是的，但有一个片段，那里有日本技术大学的博士生，他们说这个算法做了什么，他们制作了一个没有头的僵尸，但它用它的腿走路，或者有一些……它用它的手臂走路，它就像这个突变生物，而且那里……它就像为了一个视频游戏，从相机，他们都像真的很自豪
of Miyazaki's just like if you want to make horrible things like this go ahead but I think and But yeah, he is not, and he ends with him kind of saying, I think humanity's lost faith in itself. Like we're kind of trying to create something that saves us instead of saving ourselves. And I think that was almost 10 years old, that clip now. I'm sure he's not a fan of his work being able to be, for you to be able to plug in. You know? I don't think he would be happy about that.
宫崎骏只是说，如果你想制造像这样的可怕东西，那就去做吧，但我认为，而且……是的，他不是，而且他以他某种程度上说的话结束，我认为人类对自己失去了信仰。就像我们正在试图创造某种拯救我们的东西，而不是拯救我们自己。而且我认为那个片段现在已经快10年了。我敢肯定他不喜欢他的作品能够被，让你能够插入。你知道吗？我不认为他会对此感到高兴。
I'll be the dissenting voice because I actually really like Chat2PG. But I think, but I have some beliefs about I have some views there because I think it I think you have to already have like know a lot in order for it to be useful in the way that it can be very useful. It's like you have to know exactly what you're what you're trying to find and like, I don't know it it's, it's interesting though, once you get it to kind of. No, I think that's true is you have to know what it is. I mean, I use I use quad AI and chat GBT all the time. They're great for organizing information. They're great for summarization. I think they can't make intellectual leaps or kind of ideological connections between information in the way that a human can. or kind of ideological connections between information in the way that a human can.
我会成为持不同意见的声音，因为我实际上真的很喜欢Chat2PG。但我认为，但我有一些信念，关于……我有某种观点，因为我认为它……我认为你必须已经，就像知道很多，为了让它在它可以非常有用的方式中有用。就像你必须确切地知道你正在，你正在试图找到什么，而且，我不知道它……它很有趣，一旦你让它有点……不，我认为那是真的，是你必须知道它是什么。我的意思是，我使用……我一直使用Quad AI和ChatGPT。它们对于组织信息很棒。它们对于总结很棒。我认为它们不能像人类那样在信息之间进行智力飞跃或某种意识形态联系。或者像人类那样在信息之间进行意识形态联系。
What if it can? What if it can? What if it does? Yeah. Are we in trouble then? I think they'll get better at it. But the problem right now is that like, they're not really generative.
如果它可以呢？如果它可以呢？如果它做了呢？是的。那我们有麻烦了吗？我认为它们会在这方面做得更好。但现在的问题是，它们并不是真正的生成式。
They're iterative because they're discovering things that were connections somebody else already made. Even if it doesn't know why that was there or who to figure it out, it's there in the probability of language. Yeah. But they're essentially kind of like probability management engines that are going to be designed to mess with the probability of language or code based on something else that already exists. But without training data, without a vacuum, they can't really do anything, you know, in the leap of consciousness. And I don't know, maybe this is a bigger episode, but all of the theories of consciousness that I like, like Demacia and Gozniaga and the older kind of like
它们是迭代式的，因为它们正在发现别人已经做出的联系。即使它不知道为什么它在那里，或者谁去弄清楚它，它就在语言的概率中。是的。但它们本质上有点像概率管理引擎，旨在根据已经存在的其他东西来干扰语言或代码的概率。但没有训练数据，没有真空，它们真的不能做任何事情，你知道，在意识的飞跃中。而且我不知道，也许这是一个更大的剧集，但我喜欢的所有意识理论，像达马西奥（Damasio）和加扎尼加（Gazzaniga）以及较老的，像
Jungian people, it's about it being a result of like opposing forces that do not get along and have these contradictions that can't be resolved logically and so we need like a metaphorical or a symbol based system in order to like understand it and I think It's that computers have multiple inputs that disagree a lot of the time But what they don't have is like a second layer of understanding that can get outside of language to help understand the limitations of language I think that's something that is uniquely human that you need a very layered processor to do that. I don't even know how you would code something like a subconscious, you know,
荣格（Jungian）的人，它是关于它是相互对立的力的结果，这些力并不相处，并且有这些不能逻辑解决的矛盾，所以我们需要像一个隐喻或基于符号的系统来理解它，而且我认为……是计算机有多个输入，很多时候不同意，但它们没有的是像第二层理解，可以跳出语言来帮助理解语言的局限性，我认为那是人类独有的东西，你需要一个非常分层的处理器来做到这一点。我甚至不知道你会如何编码像潜意识那样的东西，你知道，
but maybe, maybe that's a bigger, bigger episode. Yeah. That's a whole big, yeah. Yeah. There's a lot of, a lot there for sure. I think Alice is going to side with the Terminator. That's what that was. No, I think that as long as you're in the light, as long as then you're fine, it's going to be fine. It's going to be like it can only augment, I think,
但也许，也许那是一个更大的，更大的剧集。是的。那是一个很大的，是的。是的。肯定有很多，很多在那里。我认为爱丽丝会站在终结者那边。这就是那是什么。不，我认为只要你在光中，只要……那么你很好，它会没事的。它会像它只能增强，我想，
what we can do. I think there's terrible stuff that's, but I think it's, it could solve cancer like that, like stuff like that. I mean, and there's things like that once you realize like how it can consolidate like research and all this stuff that, like, it could take it like three days to do that, to like analyze all the research ever and be like, here's how to cure herpes. No, I think that's it. I think the database is for like the law and for like published research, that's where those will shine.
我们能做的事情。我认为有可怕的事情，但我认为它是，它可能像那样治愈癌症，像那样的事情。我的意思是，一旦你意识到它如何能巩固像研究和所有这些东西，就像，它可能需要三天时间来做那个，来分析所有的研究，并说，这是治愈疱疹的方法。不，我认为那是它。我认为数据库是用于像法律和像发表的研究，那是那些会闪光的地方。
Cause they can sort of like filter the information and discard what's not helpful very quickly in a way that even the search engine can't. It is funny though that all of the when those came out like immediately all of the like big political like Harvard Yale figures started trying to cancel each other because it came out that like all of their PhDs were just like plagiarized basically when LL ones were invented you could detect that super quickly and they all tried to cancel each other for like a second. And then they moved on because they realized like,
因为它们可以某种程度上像过滤信息并非常快地丢弃没有帮助的东西，以一种连搜索引擎都做不到的方式。不过很有趣的是，当那些出来时，立即所有像哈佛、耶鲁的大人物都开始试图取消对方，因为出来说，像他们所有的博士学位基本上都是剽窃的，当LLM被发明时，你可以非常快地检测到这一点，他们都试图取消对方一秒钟。然后他们继续前进，因为他们意识到，像，
you can't cancel everyone in academia who did plagiarism because it's everybody. It's kind of like when the opposite team wants to impeach the other people's president, and then they're like, or not impeaching, but like do legal stuff. And then the system's kind of like, yeah, no, we don't do that at that level because we can't actually prosecute a president
你不能取消学术界所有剽窃的人，因为那是每个人。这有点像当对方团队想要弹劾对方的总统时，然后他们就像，或者不是弹劾，而是像做法律上的事情。然后系统有点像，是的，不，我们不在那个层面做那个，因为我们实际上不能起诉一位总统
because then, I don't know. Well, that sounds good. I know you'll get some other stuff coming up we can wrap up unless you all have anything that, anything else to kind of throw in? that um anything else to kind of throw in? I don't think so I mean I think it'll be fun. Yeah. Sounds good anyone want to take the lead on any of those or have like uh anything that jumps out you want to do next next month we can uh we'll see we'll play right here. Yeah we'll
因为然后，我不知道。好吧，那听起来不错。我知道你会有其他事情出现，我们可以总结，除非你们所有人有什么，有什么其他东西要加入？那……有什么其他东西要加入？我不这么认为，我的意思是，我认为这会很有趣。是的。听起来不错，有人想在那些方面带头，或者有像……有什么跳出来你想下个月做的吗？我们可以……我们会看到，我们会在这里玩。是的，我们会
play right here I definitely want the dragons. I want the dragon stuff. You know, all right. Maybe the dragons will be the next one. We'll look on a dragon episode. Oh, gosh. Real spiritual. I don't know if y'all are ready for how we that gets. You never know. You know, probably dragging all the way down. I'm like the comic relief. So you know, I'm just here for the fun times. I thought that was me. Oh, this might be Solomon. It's Solomon for sure. Oh, I've got one. I've got one that I forgot about until now. So when you have a kid, you find yourself reading like the same children's book,
在这里玩。我绝对想要龙。我想要龙的东西。你知道，好吧。也许龙会是下一个。我们会看一个龙的剧集。哦，天哪。真正的精神。我不知道你们是否准备好我们如何……那变得如何。你永远不知道。你知道，可能一直拖下去。我就像喜剧救济。所以你知道，我只是为了有趣的时光在这里。我以为那是我。哦，这可能是所罗门。肯定是所罗门。哦，我有一个。我有一个我直到现在才忘记的。所以当你有一个孩子时，你会发现自己读像同样的儿童书，
like 900 times until they get tired of it. And I think it would be really funny to do like a children's book episode where you like, because what happens is like they become this mystical tome that like it becomes like a Buddhist meditation of reading like path of bunny, like Oh my god, so many of them though. But like to do like a children's book podcast where you just like wildly overanalyze like these things like Pete the cat, cat you ever seen Pete the cat? Yeah, it turned into like this industry where it has all these other characters and stuff
像900次，直到他们厌倦了它。而且我认为做一个儿童书剧集会非常有趣，就像你……因为发生的事情是，它们变成了这种神秘的巨著，就像它变成了像佛教冥想一样阅读像《兔子之路》，像，哦，天哪，虽然有很多。但就像做一个儿童书播客，你只是像疯狂地过度分析像这些东西，像《皮特猫》，猫，你见过《皮特猫》吗？是的，它变成了一个像这样的行业，它有所有这些其他角色什么的
But the original book is just that the cat's buttons are one by one taken away And as the cat's buttons are taken away It just walks along and sings its song and it doesn't care and even at the end When it all of its buttons are taken away, it still has a belly button So it is content and like analyzing that like a retelling of the book of Job or something Analyze the giving tree let's do that. Yeah, or One of my favorites that I rediscovered
但原著只是猫的扣子一个接一个地被拿走，而当猫的扣子被拿走时，它只是走着唱着它的歌，它不在乎，甚至在最后，当它所有的扣子都被拿走时，它仍然有一个肚脐眼，所以它是满足的，而且像分析那个，像《约伯记》的重述或什么的。分析《爱心树》，让我们做那个。是的，或者我最喜欢的之一，我重新发现的
What is it? I feel the top scuffy the tugboat is One I don't know that one. It's an old like one of the old like golden books But it's a tugboat a toy tugboat who gets is one of the old like golden books, but it's a tugboat, a toy tugboat who gets taken. The man at the toy store took, takes it home to his son who then plays within the bathtub and the tugboats like this is the best kind of life a tugboat could have.
那是什么？我觉得《拖船斯卡菲》是……我不知道那个。它是一个古老的，像古老的金书之一，但它是一艘拖船，一艘玩具拖船，它被……玩具店的人拿走了，带回家给他的儿子，然后他在浴缸里玩，拖船就像这是拖船能有的最好的生活。
And then he dreams bigger and ends up getting the boy puts him in the stream and then he gets washed out to stream. And then he keeps saying, this is, and everything along the river keeps getting bigger and bigger and more industrialized and he's sailing along and doing his little toot toot but then there's big big ones eventually he ends up back at the water and he's about to go out to sea and then there's the man and the little boy right at the end of the dock like there to there to like get him right at the end of the dock, like there to, there to like get him right at the end. It's like a very, I don't know. There's so many children's books that I like read
然后他梦想得更大，最终男孩把他放进溪流里，然后他被冲出溪流。然后他一直说，这是，而且沿河的一切都在变得越来越大，越来越工业化，他航行着，做着他的小嘟嘟，但后来有大的，大的，最终他回到了水里，他正要出海，然后那个男人和小男孩就在码头的尽头，在那里……在那里……像在码头的尽头得到他，在那里……在那里……像在尽头得到他。这就像一个非常，我不知道。有很多儿童书我喜欢读
and I'm like, whoa, that's, it's actually very, very profound. Yeah, it does sound like a dissolution under the integration of consciousness. Yeah, it really is. Cause he's all of a sudden like, oh, it's kind of scary out here. Like, but I'm just going to toot my tugboat horn
而且我就像，哇，那，它实际上非常，非常深刻。是的，它确实听起来像意识整合下的解体。是的，它确实是。因为他突然就像，哦，这里有点可怕。像，但我只是要嘟嘟我的拖船喇叭
and keep going. Wow. Yeah. I think that'd be a fun episode. Maybe we have to wait till James has kids. I don't know. We'll see. Maybe. I don't know. I love kids. I've worked in preschool often over a long time. I swear there's like a whole subplot that's implied in Curious George Goes to the Hospital, where like, I think the man in the yellow hat maybe has like a child on the side or like an unknown, like there's too many coincidences in various George Goode hospitals. So we don't have time to go through that one. Yeah. Betsy, the girl at the hospital, she's the only one in the whole series that has the same color tie as the man in the yellow hat. Her dress is the same as his tie with the dots.
然后继续前进。哇。是的。我认为那会是一个有趣的剧集。也许我们必须等到詹姆斯有孩子。我不知道。我们会看到。也许。我不知道。我爱孩子。我长期在幼儿园工作。我发誓在《好奇猴乔治去医院》中有一个隐含的整个子情节，就像，我认为戴黄帽子的人可能在外面有一个孩子，或者像一个未知的，就像在《好奇猴乔治去医院》中有太多的巧合。所以我们没有时间去经历那个。是的。贝琪，医院里的那个女孩，她是整个系列中唯一一个领带颜色和戴黄帽子的人一样的人。她的裙子和他的带圆点的领带一样。
Wow. Gosh, you are going really down the conspiracy theory rabbit hole there. as the man that her dress is the same as his tie with the dots. Wow. Gosh, you are going really down the conspiracy theory rabbit hole. Yeah, there's some there's some great posters, like, because they're very like, I guess they're written in the 50s or 60s. But like, there's like so much that there's like these posters on the outside of the hospital to say, come get your leg leg x-rayed right now in this hospital. Like, it's just an advertisement for people on the street. Let's go get up. Yeah, they did that.
哇。天哪，你真的陷入阴谋论的兔子洞了。就像那个男人，他的衣服和她的领带上的圆点是一样的。哇。天哪，你真的陷入阴谋论的兔子洞了。是的，有一些很棒的海报，因为它们看起来像是50年代或60年代写的。但是，医院外面有那么多海报，上面写着“现在就来这家医院拍腿部X光片”。这就像是给街上的人看的广告。我们去拍吧。是的，他们确实那样做过。
They threw x-rays around like my godmother could remember when just to be like high tech, when you would go to the shoe store, they would x-ray your foot just to be like, oh, we have to get the fit right for your boot or whatever. X-ray your foot. Yeah, completely. Yeah, there was no reason it was live. It was like you put it into a box. It wasn't even a film x-ray. So just tons of gamma radiation for no reason. Yeah. Just like, yeah. When did you say that was? She was old.
他们到处乱用X光，我教母还记得，当时为了显得高科技，你去鞋店买鞋时，他们会给你的脚拍X光，只是为了说“哦，我们要确保你的靴子合脚”之类的。给你的脚拍X光。是的，完全是这样。是的，根本没理由，它是实时的。就像你把它放进一个盒子里。那甚至不是胶片X光。所以毫无理由地接受了大量的伽马辐射。是的。就像，是的。你说那是什么时候？她年纪很大了。
I mean, she passed away. So I don't have to look it up, but I did Google it. Like there was a period where they to upsell you. They would be like, oh yeah, this shoe is best for you. No, for real. I mean, good shoes are like, you know, one, two, three, four, five. You can't like, like, you don't need to x ray the boats. And then they came up with like, like the metal thing that you just measure your feet
我是说，她已经去世了。所以我不用去查证，但我确实谷歌了一下。确实有一段时间，为了向你推销，他们会说“哦，是的，这双鞋最适合你”。不，说真的。我是说，好鞋就像，你知道，一、二、三、四、五。你不需要给靴子拍X光。然后他们发明了那种用来测量脚的金属装置。
on. That was the advanced technology. Well, it's been great connecting and we'll look forward to getting into these. We'll kind of continue to do some of the interviews and then hopefully once a month or every two weeks we can connect and do a roundtable, you know, and sometimes bring a friend. We should do a D&D episode on like the collaborative storytelling and then have a Kearney back on because that Halloween episode with the psychology of death, that was one of the more the and all of the October ones. We could do another version. The artwork in my office that's like a formaldehyde bottle came from a listener who drew it from that episode.
那才是先进技术。好吧，这次交流很棒，我们期待深入探讨这些话题。我们会继续做一些采访，然后希望每两周或一个月能连线做一次圆桌会议，你知道，有时带个朋友。我们应该做一期关于协作讲故事的龙与地下城（D&D）节目，然后请Kearney回来，因为那期关于死亡心理学的万圣节节目，那是十月份所有节目中比较出色的一期。我们可以再做一期。我办公室里那幅画着甲醛瓶的艺术品，是一位听众根据那期节目画的。
There's something on the side of it that... Yeah, but that's what it is. They sent it. What were the other ones? I don't remember. I guess I don't ever see the release schedule. You were saying there are other October episodes? You mean the Scary Stories ones? Yeah, I think I don't ever see the release schedule. You were saying there are other October episodes. You mean the scary stories ones? Yeah, I think some ghost ones. Oh yeah, we could go there.
它侧面有一些东西……是的，但这就是它的样子。他们寄来的。还有其他的吗？我不记得了。我想我从没看过发布时间表。你说还有其他的十月节目？你是说那些恐怖故事节目吗？是的，我想我从没看过发布时间表。你说还有其他的十月节目。你是说那些恐怖故事节目吗？是的，我想还有一些关于鬼魂的。哦，是的，我们可以聊聊那个。
Yeah. Yeah, we definitely, I'm glad we've got multiple contributors now. We need to do, this October we'll do like a cool, like ghosts and hauntings episode. Anything paranormal in there. Yeah. Sounds good.
是的。是的，我们绝对很高兴现在有了多位贡献者。我们需要做，这个十月我们要拍一期很酷的关于鬼魂和闹鬼的节目。里面包含任何超自然的东西。好的，听起来不错。
Yeah. Well, thank you guys so much. Check out the website at www.gettherapybirmingham.com. And if you want to support the podcast, you know, we sell the the t-shirts and the bumper stickers and stuff, but those are mostly at cost. But what would be really helpful, and it might help you out too, as I recently found out that I'm the heir to a kingdom in Africa, but I can't afford the taxes on the inheritance. So I think that if you guys want to go to our Patreon for just a thousand dollars, you know, I can give you a million if you'll just go ahead. Parody, parody, please don't do that. We don't have a Patreon. So it doesn't matter much. Yeah, anyway, like I'm a child. People are gonna like set up a Patreon now. Yeah.
好的。非常感谢大家。请查看我们的网站 www.gettherapybirmingham.com。如果你想支持这个播客，你知道，我们卖T恤、保险杠贴纸之类的东西，但那些基本是成本价。但真正有帮助的，可能对你也有帮助的是，我最近发现我是非洲某个王国的继承人，但我付不起遗产税。所以我想，如果你们愿意去我们的Patreon捐赠一千美元，你知道，只要你们愿意，我可以给你们一百万。戏仿，戏仿，请不要那样做。我们没有Patreon。所以这不重要。是的，总之，我像个孩子一样。人们现在会去建立一个Patreon的。
Oh, no. Yeah, I think they have to have my banking information. But yeah, so anyway, thank you guys so much and we will see you next week. All right. Bye, guys. Bye. 🎵 There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，不。是的，我想他们必须有我的银行信息。但总之，非常感谢大家，我们下周见。好的。再见，各位。再见。🎵 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。